modern war applications are a mesh of
many lego blocks you can use
different cloud vendors it's highly
scalable
uh not everything is served from one
place so forcing everything to go
through a single gateway even if it's a
cloud gateway is
is adding friction welcome to 20 minute
leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc funded in silicon
valley
in partnership with lumitec and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford my next guest only started
programming in his 20s yet today he is
the cto
of an extremely fast growing cyber
security company he also ran his first
half marathon
completely underprepared previously he
only ran about half
of that distance meet idosa frutti
co-founder and cto of perimeter x
he does the co-founder and cto at
perimeter x a behavior based web
security service
at perimeter x it owns the product
vision and delivery with product and r d
reporting to him
prior to founding it idol was senior
director of product management at akamai
joining akamai through the acquisition
of contendo where he was vp of product
and strategy
he started his cyber security career in
the israel intelligence after graduating
from the telpeot program
he does welcome to 20 minute leaders how
are you all the way from beautiful and
sunny miami
i'm very well happy to be here thanks
for having me
i i'm very happy to have you here uh
this is the second time
that i'm recording a show with you the
previous time was
for a one-minute episode of tldr where i
tried to summarize
very cool startups within one minute i
remember that perimeter x was it was an
especially challenging one because there
was so much to talk about
that it just felt like one minute wasn't
enough
but luckily now we have 20 minutes so i
i
i made a big leap there but now 20
minutes we have it we have more than
enough time hopefully to to at least
scratch the surface before we get to
perimeter x though
i'd love to hear a little bit about you
and i have to start
with the story of of running the half
marathon
and i have a personal resonation with
that so so go ahead and
share with me exactly what happened
there sure
so this was actually a few months in
to a little over 11 years ago a few
months
after i moved to the u.s i've been
running for a few years already but i
always like
short distances 6k to the longest i did
was 12k
but i felt like i can felt really
cool and that if i can do 12k why not
just continue
so a company a
friend from work uh she's a runner for a
long time said oh there is a half
marathon here in san jose
join me i obviously registered
didn't think i need to do any any
preparations
showed up ran the first 12k very
good and she was a fast runner i was
trying to stick to her and then
around the 50 started slowing down and
the 15k i hit the wall
walked for a few minutes uh took some
breath and and continue and i ended up
finishing it
uh in actually a better time than i i
expected
because the first half was so fast and
unpredicted
uh but it was really brutal and then
i got excited and started booking
additional half marathons but obviously
deciding to not be uh so so uh
uneducated and and downloaded some plans
and and training
uh programs from from the internet and
started running and building a routine
and obviously the the following ones
were much easier
uh where you can recover within a few
hours and not
and not take two days off to rest
uh and i learned a lot from it i mean
sometimes you see a target that seems
like a little more than what you're used
to and you say okay i'll just wing it
i'll go there
holding for a little longer versus
doing what is totally available is
reading
looking what other people have learned
what have the video done
what do you need to prepare for what
what should you be aware of when doing
that
and and and make sure that you're there
for the best
best possible way as well as just
practice if you're if you did something
before the actual event then
the actual event will be much easier
right so
yeah i actually have a you know a very
very
a similar experience also with with a
with a race
uh here in a lot actually a few years
ago and i'm actually still recovering so
you know two days
i wish it was two days it's actually
been about three years
and i'm i still have to see a
physiotherapist from time to time so i
can very much resonate with both
the you know the obstinance to
to get the mission done but also
learning
to do it responsibly and to uh and
and to be patient about it and
responsible about it so so i think we
already have more to talk about right
after this
but but you know moving on to more of
the the technical side of your story
going through the extremely you know
amazing talpiyot
program in israel and one of the things
that i was astonished when i
in our you know interactions you
mentioned that you only started
coding in your 20s that's really
irregular uh especially for somebody in
in your position as cto of of perimeter
x but also holding
you know vp positions in in a variety of
previous companies
right right so i've had a
odd childhood maybe uh i mean
i always was curious about many things
uh and in school i liked art i liked
music
i liked history literature sciences
uh and programming always seems the
practical thing to do i like
i i loved math and physics and when when
going to topia i was sure this is what
i'm going to do
and this is where i focus my attention
uh
and when when i had reached the
end of the three years training i
realized actually
none of the places that i i would
want to that are the possibility for
pure math or
pure um physics uh
are not that interesting for me uh and i
realize that
i i don't feel passionate i feel
passionate about theory less about the
practical
aspects of it and the opportunities to
build things and to
do things in networking communication
and programming i started feeling very
appealing so it's more
of the engineering and the more
practical thing
side that drew me and and then at the
last six months of the program where i
already had all the
plans set and then i've realized okay
actually i want to do something
different
and started learning and and catching up
on
computer sciences and then my my first
job obviously
was programming so i with no experience
i was thrown into the water here build a
new
cyber group
that will identify and learn things
while i
honestly barely know programming how to
program
i do know how to learn read a bunch of
books started
doing things and and been doing it since
i love it so you were vp product and
strategy of contento
and then uh acquired and then
senior director of product management at
akamai and now perimeter x
so give me you know a little bit
holistic view of
you know your your entrance into the
cyber security field with perimeter x
we're talking about you know user
behavior tell me a little bit about what
you guys are doing
sure sure so
i started again my as i just said like
the early part of my career
in the israel intelligence was mostly
around cyber
and computer sciences but more on cyber
security
and all that and when i left the army i
said okay i'm done with cyber
i want to do other things and i was
doing uh
internet infrastructure so large
websites
uh highly scalable sites this is
so running uh medica fed then then
contendo building is
a large highly scalable modern cdn got
acquired with akamai
expanded the building infrastructure and
then before starting perma-x so me and
the co-founders we
we realized that we're seeing a gap in
the industry on
securing modern web architecture modern
web applications
usually web security was done until
until us or
the view that was common is more taking
the enterprise approach for security
have a gateway and
pass everything through that
and just force it onto the cloud and it
doesn't work because it's not fully
scalable
uh modern web applications are a mesh
of many lego blocks you can use
different
cloud vendors it's highly scalable
not everything is served from one place
so forcing everything to go through a
single gateway even if it's a cloud
gateway is
is adding friction right and
it came to a point where we say okay we
know very well the scale
that how to build a scalable web service
and what do you need
what's the infrastructure to look like
we have the foundations in the
background of
understanding deep security now how if
we would design a security service
for web scale from the grounds up how
would we build it
and the first thing that we said we
definitely don't want to build a cdn we
definitely don't want to build a
proxy service because there are enough
doing it and it won't cover everything
so we came with an architecture of
let's integrate to all these components
that are out there that people are
building on
and make this infrastructure smarter
let's integrate by collecting
information from them so that we can get
the signals and analyze them in our
cloud
and also get the network effect we can
be infinitely scalable because we're
running it
and then instrument back into that
integration
layer uh the mitigation or the actions
that we want to do based on the analysis
that the data that we analyze so at the
core of it where
we're an infrastructure play that
integrates into
modern cloud infrastructure collecting
information and then
enforcing decisions or helping our
customers make smarter decisions
but this is a platform nobody buys a
concept like this
this is where we had this concept we
started talking to customers
or potential customers and said hey what
a what do you think about this
this this concept versus the existing
ones be
what kind of problems are you seeing and
what kind of problems would you want to
solve if you would have such an
architecture and we got very strong
uh feedback and recognition on on this
is a good idea
and six years ago when we started the
company
the the main problem customers wanted is
uh
bot mitigation uh how can they identify
bots there were a few solutions out
there they were mostly proxy based or
like box-based and they were not doing a
good enough
job so we we took that as a challenge
that was the first product we built on
this platform
okay and so you're raising the team
you have offices in miami you have
offices i know in the bay area as well
and so what has been you know as your
as you're you know growing the company
if you're looking back over the past few
years and the different challenges of
the different you know experiences
what would have been some of the most
both exciting and the challenging
aspects of it
it's a rollercoaster from day one i mean
uh
a day may be the best day of your life
and the worst day of life in the same
day
based on investors
employees customers opportunities
anything that is happening is is just so
extreme
it's yours and when you're growing and
especially at such a rate
so on day one it would be we the
entire team were based in in silicon
valley uh in the bay area
uh but we decided that all of three
founders being israelis we
are our deep connections of where to
hire good engineering and research would
be in israel
so from day one we we we decided on a
very
uh demanding infrastruc architecture or
or structure for the company where we
are all three of us are
are in california but the first hires
are intel v
which meant that i spent half of my time
in tel aviv that year
wow building the team hiring the first
employees
and it's obviously much harder to hire
employees when they come
to a vision but don't see a team i mean
right everyone is is remote so how do
you get the first employees how do you
get the right culture there without
being there so
that was a very big challenge and and
this is before
before before it was mainstream yeah for
everybody to be remote
exactly exactly it wasn't easy to to
work remote
i had to spend a lot of my i spent i
don't remember i did a calculation maybe
30 days
in aggregate on planes on that year
so so not not a fun year wow
but also an extremely fun year and
building
getting the first beta customers getting
the first orders getting
uh funding getting the team so so very
exciting
uh to build that and we were extremely
fortunate that the first employee we
hired actually
was just recently promoted to be vp of
uh engineering
wow and we hired him as a as an engineer
and we had amazing luck finding him
and build the team and he has a major
part also of the success and
of building and getting the culture and
driving things
that that's really incredible do you
think it was by accident that he
that the first employee became vp
or were you looking already in the
beginning for the best engineer you
could find or
were you looking because i'm imagine i'm
putting myself in the situation where
you know hiring the first engineers and
you just want to get things moving and
you want to hire people that could get
the job done and you're eager
to build this out how did how
was it what was the thinking process
behind that
honestly i mean i think there is a lot
of luck and obviously
there are all the subconscious things of
knowing
what type of person are you looking for
and for me that definitely in the first
employee but still whenever i'm hiring
uh to a startup and to a company even at
our size today
i'm not looking for a for the best
engineer that
that will get the perfect algorithm out
there
because i'm not hiring a an assistant
professor for something i'm looking for
someone who has a
big system view who cares about the
problems and has the urgency and
to get things done uh and
is that measure when you look for that
personality it is
it's hard there is a lot of sense and
sometimes you get things wrong
some people can can communicate
great through the interview process and
not deliver
there are some people who are just great
interviewers
but but you can sense that i mean you
can sense on the urgency on the passion
how are they handling how are they doing
things what did they do in the past
even asking simple questions like when
you ask an engineer
questions about the system that he built
ask about what was to the left and to
the right
and what was before and
you'll be surprised how many people know
to describe in detail the things that
they built but they don't really care
about the reasoning they don't
understand where it fits in the big
picture
and this is something that that you can
easily clear out and sometimes you may
hire someone who
has two years of experience in in
programming but because that person is
so smart and curious he will know
everything about the company and and the
behind the scenes and all that and
and that's when you find someone like
that you should grab them and
and make sure you're not stopping them
right
and so throughout your career it looks
like you've you've been
you know on this intersection of product
and
technology for pretty much uh most of
your career right is it also
starting to code right at 20 when you're
talking about your curiosity
earlier on it sounds like that's sort of
almost like the product side of you and
and then you're you're intersecting with
the technology so so
who are you are you are you product are
you engineer
how who's he doing i'm a founder
yeah so i think i'm a founder is a
better definition because
you need a bit of both so i'm a
technical technology or technical
founder i mean i like
to solve problems i like to build things
i like to
to understand how things are working and
what moves people
so it's you need a bit of both uh i
won't
be probably the best person to
and when i when i was and that that that
was the switch that happened to me at
the age of 20
when i figured that i don't want to be
the
entire childhood with education and it's
very common that your teachers are
always uh and the
education system is trying to make you
idolize people like einstein or people
like uh
galileo or like uh people who are
uh doing everything and knowing things
very deep but are very
theoretical and i was sure i'm going to
to be that
and i realized that what actually keeps
me
excited is is solving things and
building things
and understanding what motivates and
what what makes the difference
yeah and it does need to be the
prettiest design
and it doesn't need to be just need to
be good enough to work and to get you to
the next step
right now that that's a bit of a product
just a bit of an architect is a bit of
everything
yeah i love it okay you don't are you
ready for some fun questions
sure all right so we'll start off easy
and you know whatever comes to mind so
number one
favorite subject in school k to 12.
i think there were a few uh
music probably my favorite wow
my on my high school i actually
majored i went to the israeli arts
and science academy in jerusalem uh wow
going in thinking i'll do science but i
fell in love with music there and
and actually i majored music uh there
as well what instruments did you play if
any
i was playing the trumpet uh okay
which is not the friendliest instrument
to play when you're
living in an apartment but yeah
i love it okay amazing one of your role
models
throughout your life real or fake
yeah that's a hard one um
that's a hard one um
there are a few cliches um
on kind of famous founders and there are
role models to some extent
escape for now and three quests three
words you would use to describe yourself
yeah so i mentioned it earlier curious
definitely
maker or builder and
it's not one word but
i learned in the last year that i really
like to be home
really so and and what is home is that
is that you know the family is that
literally the the physical home
what do you constitute this day in the
home yeah in my physical home
and being in my physical home
and doing things from there i mean it
just
you can appreciate your time better you
you can get from one station to another
very efficiently you don't need to go
through commuting
uh you can do things i i i've been
cooking a lot i've been
just doing things at home a lot that are
really
uh there is this time when when you work
from
an office there is the drive to and
drive back that sort of helps you reset
today and transition from work to
to home and that was my biggest concern
with coped
when covert head is how do i sort of
separate the private life and and
the personal life and and one thing that
i didn't mention is also i mean
one of the three co-founders is my
husband
that we live with together so the early
days of the company and definitely covet
so it was home and work
all mixed together that's literally
mixed together
100 mixture yeah exactly
wow so uh so figuring out how to build
the
the the gra the right balance
environment at home where
i can work out i can cook i can i
find the hooks in the day that sort of
helps you shift from one
station to the other really helped me
appreciate
home and and living at home and enjoying
that simple things
i i think that you know we have to do a
whole other episode about you know
the the intensity and exhilaration of
creating a company with a partner
because i can't even imagine
you know what what that's like
especially during covet
but for now 20 minutes is is not nearly
enough but but really thank you for
thank you for coming and for sharing
with me you know part of your story i
really appreciate it
and for now you know stay safe and stay
healthy until next time
thank you you too thank you
you